[Music]  I've never seen a restaurant like this  I'm on ice orders ready in 30 seconds  not 30 minutes franchisee the damn thing  how the heck you don't a fast-food  empire one word persistence there should  be McDonald's everywhere sea to shining  sea  I could be growing this thing at twice  to pay to teachers hang up on it unless  we got violently disconnected there  should be big windows no sponsorship no  barbecue beef no I am through with you  and your endless parade of knows what is  it with this guy business is war it's  not a dog I'm gonna take this uture I  want to win these our nose gonna be  enough for you probably never there are  funny things we could do to make a quick  buck but that doesn't mean we should be  hung up again damn ray the founder  something nobody told you